he may look like an ordinary cuddly toy
but tablet monster is much smarter than
Matt chips and software from Israeli
startup SIBO help him connect to his
alter ego on screen transforming him
into a smart toy developing smarter is a
complicated desk long test it's risky
and takes a lot of time there for SIBO
developed a complete accommodation
little toy companies to develop small
toys faster easily in any more safer way
big boys like Lego and its fusion range
and Activision whose Skylanders have
sold more than a billion dollars
probably don't need Zeebo there are
plenty of others that do I think having
a dedicated team outside that's really
working on the technology hurdle and
have the toy companies work on the play
pattern the experience the licenses etc
I think that would be a good
collaboration and a lot of toy companies
frankly don't have the budgets or the
time of the manpower to devote to to the
challenge so taking a solution from an
outsider like Zeebo is a good way to go
with more than 70 million children
apparently crying out for smart toys
sebo says manufacturers are eager to get
on board the first sebo enabled smart
way to hit stores in time for next
Christmas is this it's pebbly and it
comprises a number of characters such as
fireman Freddy here and paint a poppy
who play out a story both on the tablet
and on a board all of which is
controlled by the child sebo powered
smart toys all apply perfectly good fun
to me but I'm not the target market is
it fun girls at a fun game of course if
toy companies the world over start using
see both technology to make smart toys
there's a pretty good chance your
children will never give you back your
tablet